[Musique]
en finale du tournoi de balle en Suisse
la cinquième de la saison
le Québécois ne perd pas tant avant de
prendre le match en main il brise le
jeune danois de 19 ans dès le 4e jeu un
jeu d'avance qui suffit au Québécois
pour remporter la première manche 6-3 le
deuxième engagement est plus disputé les
deux hommes batailles ferment au service
le défi est maintenant de savoir qui
flanchera en premier et ce sera le jeune
danois alors au service à 5,5 il n'en
fallait pas plus au glyassim remporte le
jeu suivant et remporte sa quatrième
victoire de la saison il termine le
tournoi sans avoir cédé un seul jour au
service et compte désormais 13 gains
d'affilée une séquence impressionnante
qui ajoute à cette fin de saison hors
norme les années d'attente rendent le
moment encore plus incroyable
ce troisième titre consécutif apprécié
obtenu à Florence et à Anvers rapproche
un petit peu plus le neuvième joueur
mondial d'une place en finale de l'ATP à
la mi-novembre à Turin
au même moment Denis chapeau vélo a
vendu charmant sa peau en finale du
tournoi de Vienne en Autriche face à la
4e raquette mondiale le Russe Daniel
Metz le Canadien de 23 ans a bien entamé
la rencontre en s'emparant de la
première manche mais cependant ressaisi
le russe a remporté les deux manches
suivantes pour célébrer son deuxième
titre de la saison en trois manches de
4,6 6 3 et 6-2 une semaine de haut
calibre pour chapeau valov qui montre
les dents à cette fin de saison chapeau
valov et OGE aliasim devront vite se
remettre de leurs émotions ils seront de
retour en action dans quelques heures à
peine au dernier master de la saison à
Paris Olivier Pellerin Radio-Canada MONT